So our first rule for
our normalized table, will be that every
row has the same number of columns.
A column can be empty or zero, but we
can't have two columns in some rows and
three columns in another row.
That just doesn't make sense
in a relational database.
In fact, that's pretty much
the same thing that's going on,
when we had the food one,
food two, and food three columns.
If you have two values
with the same meaning for
a given key, they're going to need to
end up in separate rows, like this.
Second rule, some one or
more columns of the table are the key,
which identify what thing
each row is telling us about,
like an animal, a species,
a bank account number, a website user.
In a simple table,
like majors, it may be that all of
the columns are part of the key.
Any other columns in the table
besides the key have to
describe something about the key.
In any row, the key provides the topic
of the sentence that the rest of
the row says something about.
Rule 3, in a normalized table,
the non-key columns describe the key.
They don't describe
other non-key columns.
So if you had a table of items and
how many there are, and
what location their in and
the street address of that location.
To normalize that you don't split
out the mapping from location to
address from the rest of the table,
like so.
That way you can talk about a location
without talking about a particular item.
It's not as if the street address is
specific to a particular item after all.
Lastly, in a normalized table,
the rows don't imply relationships among
the data that don't actually exist.
This is something to watch out for,
especially when you have multiple rows
about the same entity and multiple
facts you want to record about it.
Suppose that you have some information
about some people's work skills,
including the languages that they know.
Here Annabel knows Databases and
Linux and Data Science, and
English, and French and Arabic.
And Leon knows Data Science and
Windows, and English and Kurdish.
But Databases don't have anything
particularly to do with English,
not Linux with French.
But these rows make
it look like they do.
They make it look like Annabel's Linux
skill has something to
do with her French language ability,
and that's almost certainly wrong.
So the mapping from people to
their technology skills, and
the mapping of people to the languages
they know belong in separate tables.
So there are four rules for
normalizing tables.
There's a lot more to learn
about this topic, though.
I've put some links in the instructor
notes, that you might want to read.